Demar Hamlin returns to Instagram the 24
year old NFL players back on social
media for the first time since suffering
Cardiac Arrest during last week's
Buffalo Bills game just he uh hearing
and seeing him open his eyes amazing
he posted a couple of pics in uniform
while thanking fans for their continued
support quote when you put real love out
into the world it comes back to you
three times as much the love has been
overwhelming but I'm thankful for every
single person that prayed for me and
reached out we brung the world back
together behind this if you know me you
know this is only going to make me
stronger on a long road keep praying for
me you have so many people unite around
this challenging time you know I think
it makes a difference Demar also shared
a photo including a quote from the
doctors the moment he woke up in the
hospital he asked if his team won the
answer yes you won you won the game of
Life Bengal star wide receiver T Higgins
who tackled Demar before his collapse on
the field also gave his support in the
comments we can't come together even
Bengals and Bills fans can come together
and check out demar's teammates repping
the number three demar's jersey number
as they get ready to play their first
game since his hospitalization
and Amar he's sharing from his hospital
bed the football starts making a heart
symbol with his hands and rocking a love
for damar's shirt Demar writes in the
caption quote game time at Buffalo Bills
so when someone has a Sudden Impact to
our blunt trauma to the chest if it
happens at a specific part of the
cardiac cycle then that can lead to a
ventricular arrhythmia or an unstable
heart arrhythmia which can ultimately
lead to sudden Cardiac Arrest the the
Mars collapse occurred during the first
quarter after he made a tackle stood up
and immediately fell to the ground he
was down for about 15 minutes and after
paramedics administered CPR he was taken
off the field in an ambulance resulting
in the game's postponement yeah I mean
I'll be honestly
we have been so ingrained and just like
what's best for DeMar
both of demar's parents were at the game
and have been by his side as he receives
treatment his parents like they're
Fighters I mean they are like it's one
of the best support systems that anyone
can have and honestly it shows why Demar
is so strong-willed and caring and et's
learned the family can't thank fans
enough for all the love and support the
family is they're honestly just
incredibly thankful they just keep
saying like they're just in disbelief
like someone bought a gift by or someone
said a note card and it's like wow this
is amazing I can't believe how good
these people are to us